So today we've talked about
one particular method for
doing what's called
incremental concept learning.
We started by talking about why we
need incremental concept learning.
We have instances in the world where we
encounter a limited number of examples.
We need to discern a concept
based on those limited examples.
So we start by variablizing our current
understanding to arrive at a more
abstract notion of the concept.
Then based on new positive or negative
examples, we either generalize or
specialize our understanding.
We talked about a few heuristics for
doing this, like the forbid link or
require link heuristics.
That allow us to develop a better
concept based on new examples.
Next we'll talk about classification
where we leverage the concepts
that we developed through
incremental concept learning.
But we'll also revisit incremental
concept learning in some later lessons
as well such as through version spaces,
explanation based learning,
and learning by correcting mistakes.